[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du mercredi 26 juin sur tv 60,18
voici les titres de ce journal les
yvelines toujours en vigilance orange
pour la canicule une période forcément
sous surveillance en maison de retraite
depuis l'épisode meurtrier de 2003 de
nombreuses mesures ont été prises pour
le confort et la santé des résidents
reportage dans un ehpad à guyancourt
elle s'apprête à partir pour dix mois de
tour du monde à vélo l'art 6e alice
thomas va rejoindre les frères taurin en
amérique du sud une aventure pour
sensibiliser alan baum et rieuse cette
maladie gynécologique qui touche une
femme sur dix et puis c'est notre fil
rouge de la semaine ce vendredi ce sera
les 100 ans du traité de versailles
signé après la première guerre mondiale
le restaurant étoilé du gordon ramsay au
trianon
elle lui consacre un menu jusqu'en
octobre nous en parlons avec le chef
exécutif frédérique allard commun elles
mais avant de développer ses titres
l'enquète qui se poursuit dans la sphère
de magnanville trois hommes ont été
interpellés trois personnes ont été
interpellées à ce mardi elles font
partie de l'entourage du terroriste en
2016 un homme radicaliser avait
assassiné un couple de policiers à son
domicile jessica à schneider et jean
baptiste salvin elle le forcené avait
été abattu ensuite par les forces de
l'ordre les individus arrêtés habitat
dans la même zone que le tueur et son
complice autour des mureaux et de mantes
la jolie
l es deux autres personnes interpellées
elles en février dans la même affaire
ont été relâchés faute de preuves
suffisantes canicule et pics de
pollution actuelle la circulation
différenciées mis en place aujourd'hui
en ile-de-france est reconduite pour la
journée de demain lé véhicule non
classés avec une vignette critères 3 4
et 5 ne pourront pas circuler à paris et
dans les communes limitrophes comprises
dans le périmètre intérieur de l'a86
l'interdiction de 5h30 du matin à minuit
les contrevenants s'exposent à une
amende pouvant aller jusqu'à 135 euros
des températures bien supérieur aux 30
degrés dans le département des yvelines
ces conditions météo ont conduit à
déclencher des plans et canicule dans la
maison de retraite exemple elle retraite
à exemple dans ce journal à à guyancourt
avec amical et demi d'euros océane
bazire et audrey chaillou
madame huot est ce que vous voulez un
petit peu d'eau d'accord hydratation
régulière ventilateur volets baissés
cette maison de retraite de guyancourt
est passé en plan canicule depuis samedi
dernier
objectif éviter les risques liés à la
montée des températures qui atteignent
cet après midi près de 33 degrés le
matin ce que les filles elles font
savoir les aides soignantes à comment
dire pendant la toilette elle ouvre les
fenêtres en grand pour permettre de
rafraîchir les chambres ensuite elle
referme les volets une fois que les
toilettes sont finies elle emmène les
résidents dans plusieurs pièces qui sont
climatisées la surveillance se fait 24
heures sur 24 dès les premiers signes de
fatigue l' alerte est donnée
quand on voit qu'un résident un petit
peu plus fatigué que d'habitude ou
agressif par rapport à d'habitude là on
commence à se poser des questions on
essaie de l'hydrater et si on voit que
l'hydratation ne passe pas on voit avec
le médecin coordinateur où le médecin
traitant qui qui vient tout de suite
auprès du résident et nous dit les
consignes à suivre un encadrement qui
satisfait les 91 résidents présents
actuellement dans la structure pas trop
mal mais on s'occupe bien de nous y
voilà
je suis pas seul alors c'est déjà pas
mal on peut pas l'éviter vu le temps
qu'il fait à l'extérieur
non là on est bien ce matin m'a donné
improvisateurs la douche vous l'avez
tous les jours y'a pas de problème
ce plan canicule devrait durer au
minimum jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
dans cet établissement est les
prévisions météo pour les prochains
jours le mercure est monté à 33 degrés
aujourd'hui demain à 19 degrés prévus
dès le matin on va peut-être voir
l'animation à s'afficher à l'écran
jeudi après midi voilà 34 degrés sont
annoncées elles les journées les plus
chaudes toujours prévu pour vendredi et
samedi samedi on attend jusqu'à 38
degrés en cette période pensez à bien
vous hydrater à vous alimenter également
rester dans des endroits frais et si
justement une bonne occasion de vous
mettre dans un endroit frais pour faire
les magasins c'est le début des soldes
d'été la période des bonnes affaires se
déroulent jusqu'au mardi à 6 août
justement avec l'augmentation des
opérations promotionnelles et centres
commerciaux outlet aussi c
toujours est toujours une période
intéressante audrey chaillou hossein va
dire elles sont allés poser la question
à quelques yvelinois ce matin pour moi
les ce n'est pas pareil que ce que ça a
été avant du fait que maintenant ils
font la plupart du temps des ventes
privées pour moi j'ai constaté ce matin
qu'il y avait moins de monde car
d'habitude vraiment que ce soir
carrefour ou dans les magasins et moins
de monde tout le monde maintenant
commencer à internet ils tous je sais
pas si on peut dire que c'est toujours
aussi important au caveau parce qu'avec
l'explosion d'internet c'est sûr que ça
a perdu de l'importance mais je pense
que pour tous ceux qui aiment quand même
faire du shopping aller dans les
magasins ça reste quelque chose de
précieux à leurs yeux
moi je pense à a perdu en importance
mais ça reste toujours dans les magasins
c'est toujours important même s'il ya
beaucoup de jeux vous entendez parler de
ventes privées
ça reste important pour les gens qui
sont pas forcément très accroché à
internet et tout ça je pense à ma mère
par exemple mais pas question pour elle
de passer son été dans les magasins il
va s'élancer dans un à tour du monde à
vélo alice thomas bon soir dans ça alors
vous êtes de bois d'arcy vous allez
effectuer avec les frères taurin un tour
du monde les frères toi que l'on connaît
sur tv soixante dix huit cette aventure
elle a un but c'est sensibiliser à
l'endométriose qui touche une femme sur
dix est ce que des gens on peut rappeler
ce qu'est cette maladie
cette maladie c'est une maladie qui
touche exclusivement les femmes
évidemment ça survient
à la puberté c'est l'endomètre en fait
qui est censé s'écouler pendant les
règles qui au lieu de s'écouler migrent
et va aller se fixer sur les organes
vitaux
il valait nécrosés on c'est très
douloureux et très handicapant mais
pourquoi choisir justement de
sensibiliser la serge luis attaque assez
gravement cette maladie j'ai déjà été
opéré à plusieurs reprises pour nettoyer
les organes atteints
donc ça me paraît être le bon moment
avec ceux avec ce tour du monde à vélo
de le sensibiliser à cette maladie dont
j'ai je soutient l'association ans de
france d'accord qui m'a fait un beau
drapeau je roule contre l'endométriose
et donc ça va me permettre de parler de
l'association de parler de ce qu'ils
font est d'essayer de sensibiliser dans
les pays que je vais traverser les
femmes à cette maladie qui est bien
souvent qui met bien souvent très
longtemps à être détectée mais on n'en
parle pas c'est aujourd'hui le remercier
au nom parle un petit peu plus ces
derniers temps
moi j'ai été opéré la première fois il
ya dix ans et je savais absolument pas
ce qui était cette maladie aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu plus médiatisé mais
je pense que c'est encore beaucoup trop
méconnu et le fait de faire ce tour du
monde à vélo est ce que c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important pour que le
vélo a une place importante pour moi
c'est important de montrer que ça a beau
être handicapant au quotidien
on peut quand même vivre sa vie et vivre
ses rêves et
c'est c'est un beau projet qui m'attend
avec les frères taurin et il n'était pas
question pour moi de laisser la maladie
l'empêché de réaliser c'est ça alors
c'est dans moins d'un mois vous allez
rejoindre les frères taurin guillaume et
et kevin au chili qui sont partis dans
un tour du monde pour trois ans ils sont
de bois d'arcy comme vous mais je crois
que vous ne connaissiez pas avant
racontez nous comment comment ça s'est
fait comment vous avez connu bah
justement leur aventure et comment vous
avez fait connaissance il ya eu un
article sur eux dans la gazette de la
ville on est rentré en contact assez
rapidement parce que je suis ici que le
touriste moi même depuis longtemps et on
n'a pas réussi à se voir effectivement
avant leur départ on ça a été assez
frustrant pour moi parce qu'ils avaient
vraiment vraiment sympa et puis pendant
mes vacances à moi je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait on n'était pas très
loin eux étaient à santiago à saint
jacques de compostelle et moi j'étais à
biarritz donc à une journée deux
voitures a fait les uns des autres et
donc je les ai rejoints et vous avez
fait un trajet avec eux de saint jacques
de compostelle à lisbonne ce mondial
c'est ça jusqu'au fameux vol du vélo et
puis ensuite moi je suis moi je suis
rentré j'ai reculé
mon travail j'ai repris ma vie ma
routine est assez rapidement après que
je sois parti on a décidé que j'allais
aller les retrouver mais il fallait que
je m'organise
avec mon travail avec mon appartement je
pose un congé sabbatique
je mettre de l'argent de côté aussi
parce qu'un voyage comme ça s'en vante
pas donc on a décidé que je les rejoigne
cet été et vous allez lire joindre du
coup pour dix mois cette fois-ci cet été
ça sera au chili quel est le programme
de ces dix mois je vais aller les
rejoindre au chili alors même encore
aujourd'hui c'est pas tout à fait
décider on en parlait encore cet après
midi on sait pas exactement où ils
seront dans un mois donc pour l'instant
c'est encore un petit peu aléatoires et
puis on va remonter vers le nord par
d'autres la côte est donc le chili la
bolivie le pérou l'équateur la colombie
le panama
après les pays de l'europe centrale chez
un petit peu moins à l'aise parce que
d'amérique centrale par dont ils sont
assez petit jeu les geler si tu passes
tout en larmes
j'espère avoir le temps d'arriver
jusqu'au nord du mexique
et puis après arriver là il faudra
peut-être venir travailler
et du coup la première expérience avec
eux en espagne portugal ça vous avez
donné envie tout de suite de renouveler
oui on s'est tout de suite très bien
entendus on a été tout de suite très à
l'aise les uns avec les autres y avait
même leur petit frère qui était là avec
nous donc on était 4 quand je les ai
rejoints
voilà ça fait partie de ces rencontres
qui font qu'on est bien on est à l'aise
tout de suite il n'y a aucune aucune
gêne aucun problème donc on va continuer
comment on prépare un tel voyage 10 mois
à vélo vous disiez tout à l'heure vous
avez posé un congé mais sur le plan
peut-être physique comment on prépare un
tel voyage sur le plan physique
cette année j'ai rien pu faire j'ai été
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
réopéré de l'endométriose ya quelques
mois donc ça a remis un petit peu en
cause le départ aussi un moment donné et
j'ai fait du cumul d'emplois pendant
toute l'année pour pouvoir financer mon
projet d'accord donc les semaines ont
été très longues les horaires ont été
très longs avec les de cumul des deux
emplois et donc j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
à m'entraîner cette année donc ça sera
sur le fil j'ai fait quelques week-ends
cette année je suis allé jusqu'à au
mont-saint-michel je suis allé avec leur
maman le week-end dernier sur les bords
de loire voilà mais ça reste pas un
entraînement comme ils devraient l'être
pour un voyage comme ça mais ça viendra
sur la route et le départ il est fixé
quand exactement 4 juillet eh bien on
vous souhaite bon courage dans cette
aventure merci alice thomas on pourra
suivre je crois vos aventures sur votre
page facebook alice à vélo c'est ça qui
s'affiche en bas d'écran merci d'être
passé en plateau la direction maurepas à
présent souvenez vous en mai 2015 le
maire de la ville annonçait la fermeture
du centre nautique en raison de sa
dangerosité après plusieurs recours
d'une partie de l'opposition qui
souhaitait une réhabilitation c'est bien
une déconstruction puis une
reconstruction qui se déroule
actuellement ce matin les pelleteuses
sont entrées en action mickey les
limites d'euros et wilfrid richy après
le désamiantage place à la
déconstruction à maurepas les
pelleteuses sont maintenant à l'oeuvre
pour faire disparaître toute trace du
centre aquatique fermé depuis 2015 pour
raisons de sécurité on pouvait
réhabiliter c'était possible mais ça a
coûté beaucoup plus cher et c'était
j'allais dire est responsable vis-à-vis
des finances publiques puisque de toute
façon on est on aurait été obligé à
chaque fois de d'entretenir de refaire
des travaux puisque vous le voyez la
structure elle est complètement corrodé
les bassins n'était plus aux normes
depuis 1981 est datant des années
soixante dix l'équipement accueillait
particuliers associations et scolaires
la tante avant de retrouver les bassins
devrait prendre fin en 2021 alors
l'avenir de ce lieu c'est un centre
aquatique qui correspondent aux besoins
des habitants moderne beaucoup plus
ludique et familial que ce qu'on a connu
auparavant
on doit avoir un projet qui dure dans le
temps pour 30 ou 40 ans avec des
matériaux qui soit durable également
puisqu'on part certainement gardé des
bassins en inox qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les passants à carrelage que nous
avons connue et qui causait pas mal de
fuite pour la déconstruction
qui va se prolonger pendant l'été 157
mille euros était investi un coût
partagé avec la ville d'elancourt
elancourt qui financera aussi la
construction de la prochaine structure
tout comme la région ile de france ou
encore le département montant global 15
millions d'euros prochaine étape donc le
choix dans un concessionnaire privé en
délégation de service public ce dernier
aura un an pour réaliser la nouvelle
piscine à noter que 80 % des déchets de
ce chantier actuel seront recyclés
annonce le maire dans l'actualité locale
aussi la grève hier d'une vingtaine de
professeurs du collège blaise pascal de
plaisir rejoint par à des fédérations de
parents d'élèves ils dénoncent des
dysfonctionnements et de mauvaises
conditions de travail au sein de
l'établissement rep de 600 élèves
situation due notamment selon eux aux
mauvais lien mauvaises relations avec
leur direction ils demandent d'ailleurs
la restauration d'un dialogue un
courrier a été remis aux services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
c'était il ya cent ans le traité de
versailles été signé le 28 juin 1919
dans la célèbre galerie des glaces du
château de versailles signé entre les
alliés et l'allemagne suite à la
première guerre mondiale ce traité qui a
été pensée dans des salons du à trianon
palace pour l'occasion le gordon ramsay
le restaurant étoilé de l'hôtel propose
un menu spécial c'est jusqu'en octobre
et pour en parler frédéric l'art comme
un bon soir vous êtes le chef exécutif
du gordon ramsay au trianon pourquoi
proposer ce menu historique
sauf que c'était très important de
présenter un menu pour rendre hommage
justement traité de versailles
il se trouve que le traité de versailles
a été rédigée dans notre salon
clemenceau qui est une un salon
historique que nous avons à l'hôtel
crillon palace
ça on l'a peut être oublié que les
flancs les grandes lignes de ce traité
historique ont été tentées vraiment au
trianon palace il ya tous les
les plus grands présidents qui sont nés
ici présents justement avec georges
clemenceau lors de lors de cette
rédaction et vous disiez dans un salon
qui est nommé aujourd'hui au nom de
georges clemenceau alors pour préparer
ce menu racontez-nous je crois que vous
êtes vous êtes plongé dans les archives
oui plongée dans les archives ouvrage
internet on a réussi à trouver
deux anciens menu on a pu voir que les
chefs de l'époque ont pu le ce qui était
important c'était de montrer le point le
lien fort qui avait entre les deux pays
les états unis la france et on en a eues
trouver un de décembre 1918 et 1 2
février 1919 qui est l ouverture
officielle de la paix vous il y avait
découvert des choses intéressantes des
choses intéressantes oui on s'est
plongée justement dans ses archives pour
extraire justement des plaques ont déjà
été fait à cette époque là et d'autres
justement pour donner un clin d'oeil
aussi sur les spécialités françaises
quand vous parliez du clin d'oeil
franco-américain au lien
franco-américain
d'ailleurs le menu commence par des
oeufs brouillés aux pointes d asperges
et ça c'est un menu qui a été enfin
c'est un plat qui a été servie service
en 18 c'est ça descend 1918 le président
wilson est arrivé à brest et après
arrivant à paris
un repas officiels étaient organisés et
s'étaient l'amuse-bouche donc nous après
on a réinterprété avec nos méthodes nos
techniques nos produits un hommage aussi
au lien franco-américain avec le plat le
filet de sole à la new burg
si un seul à newburgh également qui a
été servi en décembre 1918 et c'était le
plat signature du delmonico à new york
où le chef là bas était un peu de grands
ouvrages était important c'était le
guide escoffier et
un autre ouvrage de hafner qui était
avec tous les spécialités de l'époque
aux états unis alors the épicurienne
vous disiez a aussi hommage à la france
à l'histoire de la france la poule de
houdan à la sauce soubise qui était l'un
des plats préférés de georges clemenceau
on lui a d'ailleurs consacré un
reportage à cette poule 2 ou donc voilà
la cuisine et il ya aussi la célèbre
pour la célèbre bouchées à la reine
vient les bouger de la reine qui était
qu un plat qui a été créé à versailles
par marie lundi ce qui est l épouse de
louis 15 et nous nous lavons retravaillé
avant lui rajoutant un peu de finesse
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un plat
où on a tous beaucoup de souvenirs d'un
place et l'eau il a fallu justement le
rende plus léger et en ce qui concerne
la poule d où danse était ce important
pour vous de cuisiner aussi des plats
locaux avec à diouf c'était un produit
qui était servi sur toutes les grandes
tables de l'époque lilly a 100 ans
notre on a travaillé avec eric son saut
à commander les poules en amont pour
pouvoir les servir à l'ouverture à
l'occasion du du menu de la paix donc
c'est une poule de houdan soubise qui
était le plat préféré de georges
clemenceau le travail et par sa
personnel cuisinière en fait marcel blin
on arrive au fromage le compagnon des
tranchées qu'est ce qui se cache
derrière ce nom oui alors ça c'est la
grande surprise
compagnon des tranchées en fait il se
trouve que les soldats les poilus qui
était dans les tranchées qu'on leur
fournisse énormément de fromage eu
beaucoup de ruptures de stocks de
marchandises et le camembert qui était
méconnu en fait en france
a été le fromage qui a été envoyée
justement aux poilus pendant le
pendant la guerre et plus de 1 million
de fromage sont signés et envoyé aux 30
dans les tranchées par mois donc c'est
plus de 400 pièces par jour
et voilà nous on a revisité justement le
camembert de normandie pour pour ce pour
rendre hommage à ce menu mais sa part
donc d'une anecdote assez intéressante
et enfin pour finir le dessert vous êtes
parti sur sur quoi pour cette touche
sucrée balle à mazarine mazarine flambé
à l'autre vie qui était un plat qui
était servi justement février 1919 en
regardant dans justement dans
épicurienne s'éteint c'est une variante
en fait du baba au rhum et il ya que ce
lien justement avec les bouchers de la
reine de ce que le baba au rhum c'était
le père de marie vindy ski qui adorait
manger son coup de bluff avec de
l'alcool
donc voilà ça il y avait un lien entre
justement versailles 1 plaques avaient
été servis à l'époque donc voilà nous
avons en nous servons 7 mazarine façon
babar et donc c'est un menu qui est
servi jusqu'au 31 octobre restait une
volonté de faire durer ce menu hommage
au traité de versailles en profiter un
maximum
le traité de versailles n'a pas été fait
juste une journée c'était un travail de
pendant plusieurs mois donc nous c'était
important aussi de justement offrir ce
menu est que tout le monde puisse en
profiter sur sur quelques mois mais pour
le prix comptez 199 euros par personne
pour le menu 294 euros pour l'accord
entre mais 20 merci à frédéric l'arc
demain je rappelle que vous êtes le chef
exécutif du restaurant le gordon ramsay
au trianon vie visite officielle ce
matin dans les yvelines franck riester
s'est rendu à saint germain en laye le
ministre de la culture a effectué une
visite des grands équipements et sites
culturels de la ville
au programme du déplacement la salle de
la clé le musée d'archéologie nationale
et l'église de saint-germain inscrite à
l'inventaire des monuments historiques
la chaleur qui sévit dans les yvelines
on vous en parlait au début de ce jour
on a la solution pour trouver de la
fraîcheur c'est peut-être d'aller au
cinéma une nouveau multiplexe a ouvert
ses portes au centre commercial parly 2
au chesnay rocancourt 12 salles
composent ce site est géré par le groupe
ugc reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et de nicolas d'ombré elle est bien
douce alice assez impressionnant en fait
et les très bien et les grands et elle
est sale on est bien ici il ya des
grands écrans et tout ça c'est super
c'est impeccable ses propres éléments
c'est vraiment c'était super le ser dans
cette partie mais il est vachement
moderne et bien c'est tout neuf donc
forcément c'est super cool ce mercredi
26 juin et particulier au centre
commercial parly 2 en plus des nouveaux
films de la semaine un nouveau cinéma
ouvre ses portes c'est l'ugc ciné cité
par lee 12 salles sur trois niveaux avec
une capacité d'accueil de 2200 places
on a un très bon rapport à l'écran
quelle que soit la salle dans lesquels
on sera installé avec une projection
laser dans toutes les salles et du sont
sept points
là également dans toutes les salles
l'objectif étant de pouvoir offrir aux
spectateurs et aussi au film quel que
soit le film dans la salle les
meilleures conditions de projection la
plus grande salle fait 347 place avec un
écran de 18 mètres de base
le chantier de cette construction a été
lancée en 2010 est l'aménagement du
cinéma depuis novembre
1018 on arrive par un hall qui est
complètement vitré ce hall d'accueil qui
nous permet d'arriver ensuite sur un
foyer principal qui va desservir toutes
les salles on a deux très beaux espaces
d'attentes
c'est un très bon emplacement c'est un
beau potentiel
c'est surtout qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
attente très forte autour du projet
l'ouverture de cette structure le retour
du 7ème art aux chaînés rocancourt en
juin 2014
un cinéma de cinq salles installées sur
le parking du centre commercial avait
fermé ses portes et on reste au cinéma
la lumière qui revient au resto au
cinéma pour notre petit tour du mercredi
dans les salles du territoire ce soir la
programmation du à cinéma les yeux
d'elsa à saint cyr l'école est présenté
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa deux sens hier
l'école ce week-end ce sera la clôture
de la 9ème édition du festival les yeux
pleins d'étoilés on vous attend nombreux
évidemment avec plein de films et de
nombreuses surprises et surtout un film
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
cyrano de bergerac on vous présentera le
vendredi 28 juin à 20h30 séance unique
accompagné par mois je vous ferais je me
ferai un plaisir de vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est un grand club alors
évidemment gérard depardieu son prix
d'interprétation à cannes en 90 ce grand
texte démons rostand une histoire
vraiment formidable nouvelle histoire
d'amour
un grand moment à vivre en famille à
partir de 10 ans ça sera des souvenirs
pour toute la vie et nous continuerons
dimanche 30 juin à 10 heures avec une
séance très spéciale d'un ciné conte
dans le ciel c'est une création
originale des yeux d'elsa en partenariat
avec versailles grand parc
c'est une séance gratuite alors le
principe est simple c'est un spectacle
hybride entre film il y aura la
projection de quatre films et spectacles
vivants puisque une conteuse charles
gillot interviendra entre les films et
fera de ce spectacle un moment magique
puisque elle lira en fait les histoires
et on va vivre avec elle les aventures
de stella
étoile qu'elle incarne dans sa quête
initiatique ce sera donc le dimanche 30
juin à 10 heures au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa à partir de 3 ans et c'est une
séance gratuite
[Musique]
et puis cet événement qui nous fait
revenir tout droit au 19e siècle la
troisième édition du pique nique des
peintres du petit moulin des vaux de
cernay lieu d'inspiration pour les
peintres paysagistes retour avec michael
et demi d'euros et nicolas landry le bal
au petit moulin des vaux de cernay un
retour aux traditions du 19e durant une
après-midi du 21e siècle les outils
agricoles le lavoir pour nettoyer son
linge tout cela dans le cadre champêtre
de la haute vallée de chevreuse
il y avait des tables et à l'auberge qui
étaient des tables et qui pouvaient
réunir une bonne vingtaine trentaine de
personnes en un seul jour avec toute une
série d'animations qui montre ce qu'on
faisait à l'époque
du point de vue du point de vue de la
peinture bien entendu mais pas seulement
aussi du point de vue de la détente
puisque c'était un lieu aussi de visites
de détente
le fait que ce soit complètement libre
complètement
d'époque aussi et conviviale c'est
vraiment joli et la nature elle est
à l'état
sauvage enfin j'en sais rien c'est
vraiment joli le moulin et ses alentours
une source d'inspiration pour une
colonie de peintre tout au long du 19e
romantique naturaliste et paysagistes se
sont succédé dans les 80 un tiers des
têtes d'affiché comme corot pelouse mais
aussi beaucoup de peintres étrangers qui
sont venus à paris au grand salon et qui
profitait de grands salons fournir à 40
km de paris pour rester entre amis et
aussi peindre des paysages magnifiques
que vous trouvez dans cette vallée on ne
peut
avoir comme l'admiration devant des
paysages pareil de toute façon
d'inspiration elle bien par son ménage
de végétation de minéraux et d'eau
visiteurs et peintres ont déjà noté la
date de la quatrième édition en 2020
pour une nouvelle danse de nouveaux
coups de pinceau auprès du petit moulin
des vaux de cernay et avant de vous
quitter cette information avec les
fortes chaleurs ces derniers jours des
communes des yvelines ont choisi de
fermer leur établissement après en avoir
informé le rectorat dans les yvelines
six écoles sont concernées pour les
journées de jeudi et de vendredi une à
saint martin la garenne de à gargenville
3 dans la commune du perray en yvelines
un accueil des enfants 1 sera assurée
par ces eps mairie c'est la fin du set 8
journal dans un instant le 7-8 débat
comment développer l'engagement citoyen
dans les yvelines c'est la question
posée par aurélie rose à ses invités
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]